how do you know if you're a storyteller
you love to tell stories you've been
telling stories since you could talk
you I have people that have applied to
my CBS program and they write in their
letter of interest I started writing
stories when I was five years old or I
watched somebody just did I watched
SpongeBob
Square Pants and then I wrote the up the
next episode of what I wanted it to be
and she was like six
so you know maybe you keep a journal you
are a writer you're a Storyteller if you
love telling stories what do great
storytellers have in common they have
something they need to express
they want to Delight someone they want
to scare someone they want to move
someone they want their story to make an
impact
and that's how you know if you if you
have a burning desire to get your story
and stories out there
you're a storyteller what are the key
elements of a good story the key
elements are you care deeply about the
characters and that the story has
unexpected turns things happen in it
that you wouldn't have anticipated but
they're still within the world that the
writer has created but it always comes
down to the characters it's always about
do we care about them do we love them or
can we not turn away because they're
such a train wreck
it's the characters that we're we're
hardwired for story and the Heart of a
story is
character and you can have a great plot
great plot but if there isn't compelling
characters to go with it nobody cares
how does the Storyteller make their
projects more meaningful
meaningful
I think the more personal it is the more
meaningful it is if you're willing to
tackle topics that are meaningful that
aren't just
um this is so mean but Emily in Paris
fabulous clothes you gotta love those
locations but how how meaningful is that
really if if you're willing to explore
with depth you'll find meaning
and
if you want to move people with your
work
you will find stories that are
meaningful otherwise people aren't moved
sure sure yeah I mean but it was a
successful show and and you know I
watched it it didn't move me in that way
but it was a light
it was very light right we're talking
about Emily in Paris correct we all need
entertainment too especially during the
pandemic and we're just coming out of it
I sometimes just still watch
um Big Bang Theory because I need to not
think about anything and Abbott
Elementary I adore because it's fun and
Emily in Paris is fun and it's eye candy
but is it deeply meaningful I
Storyteller stay authentic
you constantly check in with yourself
with a no BS detector and when you
create something you say is this
true for me is this really true or am I
chasing the marketplace and whatever I
think people want is what I'm going to
give them
if it's true for you
then it's authentic
if
now sometimes true for you can be so
Niche that other people can't relate to
it so
um that isn't always the best but check
in with yourself make sure that what
you're saying in the stories you're
telling that you care about them
and that's how you'll stay authentic
yeah I think that would be an
interesting dilemma is is how Niche it
is your story and we all think our story
is relatable but
um you know obviously not and if the
general audience is not in LA or not in
New York those are going to be different
stories in some sense
absolutely then they may not relate to
it it needs to be Universal when I was
at CBS and this will show you how old I
am we did Murphy Brown the first Murphy
Brown and at the time
That Dying English came in to pitch it
the the word on the street was don't do
politics nobody can relate to politics
nobody cares outside the Beltway but
those characters were so Charming so fun
so engaging that politics didn't matter
so it's about the characters
do storytellers see the world the same
as everyone else I don't think so I
think storytellers have a Keen Eye
for what's beneath the surface
that's where the richness is
interesting you know they they talk
about um in books like the drama of the
gifted child rights like that sometimes
upbringing makes you more aware of
things whether it's a survival it's by
by necessity
um let's say someone had a wonderful
childhood and it's it's not that but
they just maybe were more introspective
maybe they were an infj or ENFJ or
something and they um to go Myers-Briggs
on you yes right they uh they studied
people storytellers study people and
look for truth
if you've been
unfortunate enough
to have had a traumatic experience
growing up or traumatic childhood
you probably know how to dig deeper in
your you may not be afraid of
confronting that some people are and
they don't go there but some people who
have worked through their trauma can
bring it out in a story in a way that
other people can relate to it there's
some stories that are so difficult to
watch because they're so Raw but there's
people who who want to see that how do
you know you've met a Storyteller I a
Storyteller is somebody that has a
interesting slightly off-kilter view of
the world
that's how you can tell that you're
meeting a good Storyteller they um they
see things slightly differently they are
aware of emotions that not everybody is
can access and when I meet those people
I know it I know it and also often they
rack on tours they know how to tell a
story with a beginning middle and and
hook me that's one way to know you're
talking to a Storyteller leading with
trauma hate it okay
I hate it don't recommend it well we're
in a new you know I'm Gen X so we didn't
really do that we wanted to make sure
everything looked fluffy and beautiful
on the outside right but we're in a new
age where I'm actually pleased to see
people are okay with different things
but I think we've become so much so as
I'm this and is that okay to do or is
that a little bit too much too soon
let's wait till the second date to talk
about that I couldn't agree with you
more
on the first date
unless you're a certain kind of person
you're not going to go into the depths
of your despair the depths of your
trauma
you need to meet someone and see what
their ability to absorb that is if you
just lead with it
that can be overwhelming for people and
it can be a turn off
what I say to people is because it's so
hard to listen to that's the turn off
um
what I tell people is if you have worked
through your trauma and you can talk
about it in a way that isn't raw for you
and you can almost this isn't quite it
but you can almost toss it off
and just say this is a thing that
happened so that the person listening
doesn't have to feel sorry for you
then talk about that if it's still so
wrong that you're emotionally bleeding
from it don't go there don't go there
it's it's it's it's too vulnerable and
people really are put off I think by
somebody who's
that raw some people love it but most
people will back away from it